so uh hello to everybody and definitely
excited to be here again I think the
last time I was here outside of uh
Jennifer's class was the the
entrepreneur week and I know and base I
came and did something with base but but
anyway it was uh it was very exciting
a lot of exchanges and I'm a focus today
on you know branding personal branding
and of course utilizing you know social
media one thing I just did was I tweeted
out it said Stanford bids so would you
arm for everybody who's on Twitter right
quick just kind of check out my Twitter
feed right quick and the notes are there
the random notes just random it's a
Stanford beers and if you click on it it
has like four or five or six or seven or
eight or nine or ten or twelve little
thoughts and I'll be working kind of
from those thoughts sure sure if Scott
MC Hammer eight to Twitter because
there's a real correlation between you
know personal branding and corporate
branding and I've been watching all the
things are happening right now with some
of my favorite companies out there
obviously I'm a big fan of all the
social media companies Tristan I met
right here right Tristan came out of I
actually met him first at an event he's
over at Foursquare now but I think you
talk to Tristan all the time right so
Foursquare's wanted you know one of the
companies I really think that has got it
right along with obviously your
traditional companies and the ecosystem
around Twitter and some other yeah right
there yeah so as soon as he does that
I'll jump right into it I just came in
from Atlanta I was at the Black
Enterprise entrepreneurs conference 2011
I had a good time with that and got back
in probably around you know midnight or
1:00 o'clock I'm doing like you guys are
doing final week right you burning both
ends I asked the last class some random
questions about some current events
nobody knew anything
it's like everybody is unplugged from
everything so how many fans of Lady gaga
see now here we go
yes a bunch of Lady Gaga fans so one
thing I wanted to emphasize was a you
know personal branding I wanted to find
it right and defining a personal brand
Lady Gaga as a very good example
I would I would argue with anyone that
the culture of her brand
and by the way personal branding equates
to the culture of you so the culture of
you right so a culture of you
utilizing Lady Gaga her culture is now
bigger than the music and the music is
good and it's very big and what do I
mean by that and how did she end up
defining that culture well from one
aspect early on the community tried to
define what a brand was right and the
thing about that is is that the
community may not even be fans of your
product right so you know we have the
behaviors at iTunes there is a group of
individuals at iTunes no matter whose
album comes out doesn't matter they go
to that album to that artist site and
they attack if one star one star half a
star I hate it I hate it I hate it but
they don't even like the band they're
not even a fan of the band so it sends
out the wrong message to none fans
because they really think that someone
is reviewing the product the album and
given it negative reviews so one of the
great things about social media is what
we get to control the messaging to a
certain extent so one of the things you
want to always do is have your fans go
on your night when your product is being
released and give it to five stars all
the way down but there was a group
trying to define her brand early on who
was Lady Gaga what she's about bah blah
blah finally her in-house camp took
control of the message so once they took
control of the message you started to
see who she is socially politically and
defined her look right she her look it's
progressed by the way right so what it
is today is not the same as
two years ago but what it does is it
separates her immediately from all of
the other 20 million bands that are out
there that are trying to carve their
niche so he was like a huge fan of Lady
gaga like a huge fan big fan or a big
fan
so what would you say the culture of her
brand is if you were to summarize it
she's like the mother monster it's like
everyone's the monster offer concerts a
monster boss of the audience are little
monsters and she said this is my face I
believe in you there's some like anti
Christianity but she was so saying a lot
in her videos so that's a lot of
information right that's a lot lot of
information so if you pointed out about
seven or eight things that defined her
brand number one she mobilized her
audience and gave them a name they're
the monsters so this means that in in
many respects my fans are my fans right
so when I speak I'm not speaking to you
I'm not speaking even to the people who
go on iTunes or Amazon or anywhere else
who are not fans and make negative
comments because I make music for the
monsters that's very important that's
also very important for corporations out
there well you know this is why the
analytics work so well with the
analytics you're able to to look at the
information then do your targeting and
say this is who I'm trying to reach
right this is this is what it's all
about
we're doing that in music right now in a
way that it's never been done before
because of all the social media tools
that are available another thing that
you pointed out about Lady Gaga is that
she has a social a political message and
I think it was recently I'm not sure but
I believe was target or one of the
retailers that had a difference of
opinion I believe with
message or or the fans of our music or a
cause that she didn't agree with so she
made it known to them listen if you're
not going to support my monsters in
their their ideology then I don't
necessarily want you to carry my product
now I don't know which store that was
for sure so since we're live-streaming
but her political and social position is
as much a part of the culture of her
brand as a music so if you take personal
branding today and you want to separate
yourself if you want to do it the most
efficient way start defining defining
your brand early right to find who you
are it's no longer good enough to be the
best singer even though there's a new
show out called The Voice right and it's
about focusing on the voice previously
you could just focus on the voice and
the best singer would be the one but
today with transparency real-time all
this information available 24 hours a
day if you have to be willing to define
what your brand is what the culture of
your brand is early on and it will help
you to carve out your niche and kind of
take off and get out in front of
everybody so or at least theoretically
it can allow you to take off so I was
going to align oh can you click on that
link or I'll click on it no it's okay I
have it I know I have it so I thought I
was going to give an example of Cisco I
have any familiar with a product from
Cisco so what's the worst day one of the
products from Cisco did you're familiar
with routers anybody else random
switches and yours was most important
one because this is the point that I'm
going to make so Cisco is known for
switches and routers now this is just
analogy between personal branding
corporate branding showing it there
basically there's a lot of parallels so
they decided now that the new stable
step will be and this is going back
about eighteen months they're going to
get into their own devices they want a
brand a hardware they want a brand they
want to put Cisco on things and they
took this great piece of product that
I'm a big fan of called the flip right
and the problem was that from my
perspective it said they didn't utilize
what I'm calling again marathon branding
and start to seed the public with the
idea that Cisco would now offer more
than just routers and switches it's hard
to get people to adjust to a new
behavior from nowhere right I go down
ten miles and make a right that's where
the milk and the flour is it's art that
becomes subconsciously my habit if you
move the milk somewhere else for the
first couple of months I'm still want to
get there start to make that right and
then adjust and make the left no one was
looking for hardware from Cisco they
weren't looking for earphones and I love
the brains they're looking for switches
routers infrastructure right so the
marathon branding approach is the idea
and but the underlining thing is the
culture of you but the idea that you
start to see the new behavior early and
you stick with it so I think one of the
challenges that Cisco had was that
number one they weren't they weren't
willing to run the marathon they gave it
a shot
they tried and much to my dismay because
I'm a big fan of the flip they decided
to kill the product this it's no longer
even in the product line anymore and it
went away so when you're establishing a
new behavior when you are a brand that
has been around and you want to
transition you want to start to
introduce new features new products you
have to see to be
early another example I wanted to give
is Google as Google is beginning to move
into music which is not what you think
right you google for information right
you google for Gmail right check your
Gmail you don't necessarily Google for
music not yet
now there's rumors and there's leaks and
things that say that now Google is going
to focus on music how many are many
people in are aware of that so there's
10 or 12 people who are aware of the
music is going to be a part of the
culture of Google well my suggestion
would be to Google take a page out of
the music industry one of the very few
pages that you would take because it you
know it took a long time and the music
industry is still adjusting to what this
new world is but take a page out just
from this aspect link it we are when you
when you hear the music is being linked
from from an artist it's normally the
label themselves linking it it's not
nobody hacked into a server none of that
happened this is a way of beta testing
the product hoping that the community
will decide what the signal is if Google
is going to be a place for music then
they should go ahead and step out now
and start to talk about Google being the
place for music and a company that did
it and does it very well
Microsoft they're in the marathon
branding they'll take something like the
Xbox which is which is you know a great
I love the Xbox right great gaming
device great console and they'll say
listen we're late to the space we didn't
get in early we're going to set aside X
amount of dollars and we're going to
carve we're willing to lose money on the
hardware you know that Xbox is not a
profitable piece of hardware but we're
in it for the long haul well fine tune
the product but we're here and they
started talking about it they delivered
it's a great you know it's a great
console center of your living room and
they rolled it out and today all of us
not all of us but at some point if you
like games you've had an Xbox right and
then they integrated
which again I should actually say I
participating that I went down to New
Zealand in Australia and helped
introduce the social media integration
into the Xbox a couple years ago but I
only put that example up there that
sorry you can see that Xbox Microsoft
even with being right searched everybody
knows what being is now so Microsoft has
a history of going the distance in terms
of branding marathon branding getting in
sticking with it and riding it on this
one point would Cisco because I don't
know what the other things they were
doing but when they decided to go from
infrastructure switches to hardware I
don't think that they thought that they
would stick it out it was a test it was
an open test without declaring it as a
test so being the parallels between
personal branding and corporate branding
are very similar and there'll be even
more when you take a look now Apple one
of my favorites all time I'm any Apple
fans in here the whole room see Apple
has a way of of making sure that you
know what they're doing without saying
they're going to do it they they do it
very well
they make sure you know what they're
going to you know what's coming without
saying what's coming but it is coming
right and right now the next thing that
they're going to do and I'll come back
to this but the next thing they're going
to do is they're going to offer the
locker they want they're going to beat
everybody to music storage which the
competitors in that space Amazon the
music industry itself well you know in
some aspect possibly Facebook and Google
I don't know the intimate details I'm
just throwing it out there
but here comes Apple again out of
nowhere how did they do it how are they
getting it done and how do they do that
so fast well one is is that once they
make a decision it seems like for the
most part they stick with it they leak
out and they they make it known without
making it known that
we're coming you better be ready and
when we do it we'll make it user
friendly the interface will be great the
personal experience will be great and
the design will be great so personal
branding and corporate branding they
they're very much aligned whether it's
an artist's or whether it's a product
what I was going to say about Apple and
distribution and the music industry was
a few years ago there was you know these
deals these licensing deals that were
being cut that you know helped to set up
the iTunes Store so all labels had to
participate and I was having a debate
with some of my music industry friends
that the music industry it's no longer
in Hollywood or anywhere else in New
York but it's really based in Silicon
Valley and of course at that time they
laughed
the music industry is not in Silicon
Valley I said yes it is it's it's now
here it started with the creation of the
mp3 once the community had the ability
to download music and share music the
control of the music industry left
Hollywood New York and now it was
controlled globally by the community but
they of course they couldn't understand
at the time well the next piece was when
Apple was able to make a deal with the
labels for this little project I just
another little project we're doing
called the iTunes Store and you'll be
able to buy music here well now it's no
longer speculation but you know the bulk
of all music is bought through through
Apple and clearly the head of the music
industry the power the control is here
in Silicon Valley so when you are
defining a brand and again what was
Apple at that time by the way before
Apple was music what was Apple by the
way what did you see Apple as personal
computer I mean no personal computers
but it was it was about video right at
the end of the day it was about art
people who are into art they loved Apple
products later on
after they took over the music business
and now Netflix is doing a great job by
the way but now you know videos and
entertainment all of this equates to
Apple the culture of who they are is
bigger but not arguably not not more so
than their products because the iPhone
obviously is a great product and the
rest of their products are great but
Apple does a great great job at just
establishing their culture and also
running the distance with marathon with
marathon branding so I thought that I'd
point those out and that I would share
the fact that if you are if you're going
to shift your brand transition be a
brand that is nimble in the marketplace
going forward the fastest way most
efficient way is to utilize the social
media tools to number one to get a gauge
to test resistance to get a gauge on
what people feel about your new shift to
I said in the last class which is kind
of you know very quickly we did a real
short synopsis of it but I said you know
you take a brand that's been around for
a while in the music industry like
Beyonce when it's time to reassert
yourself take your lane back you come
out you point to things that were
affiliated and associated with you in
the past like Destiny's Child was about
independent women and you know girl
power and things like that her new song
is about
girls girls power but it's it's a new
reinvigorated her competition
theoretically right now would have been
in some aspects Rihanna and maybe a
couple other but what she did was
quickly established
reestablished her lane her brand what
the new culture will be about the
culture of her because she truly is a
marathon Brander even when she's away
she maintains a presence and continues
continue to add to the story which is
also one other point that I make this
very important is you being in control
of telling the story of who your brand
is is it is you know without a doubt the
most important aspect today because all
your competitors want to tell your story
all
it's ruthless out there right now right
if you look at the competition everybody
tells the other guy's story but when you
take and take control utilizing these
tools and tell the story yourself you're
almost unbeatable because if they say
this and you say that if you look at
Starbucks and Starbucks has retold the
news story and there is what they owe
they were in the last class there's a
couple students in the last class who
are doing something around caffeine
right and I don't know how many caffeine
lovers in here it's the only way you're
going to get through these finals
Starbucks has done a fantastic job at
repositioning the brand right because
again they run the marathon they embrace
digital and social in a big way and some
of their competitors were beginning to
get some traction but once they
reasserted themselves embraced it I'll
say since we're online
shout out to their digital head Steve
yes Steve not that I don't know your
name but I'm saying yes Steve um he does
a great job senior vice president of
understanding and pushing forth
I happen to know him where I know him
from my Twitter stream he's always on
checking people out and interacting so
if your brand has been around for a
while and you want to decide to
reposition yourself there's no better
place no better platform than social
media and using the social tools to do
that before we go too far or get too far
I had a couple I wanted to set aside at
least five or ten minutes for the answer
a couple questions and I had a couple
more things I wanted to say so I think
you had a question earlier Jim or you
made a statement earlier yeah yeah right
right and what was your thoughts around
the flip the whole we can we can call it
debacle in some aspects well I think
Cisco got into
they got a consumer product business and
they weren't focus company I had a
really hard time going I think that's
what just like that so I worked and
basically model yeah so basically what
happened was really Cisco in ability to
transition from B to B to the B to C and
the way for you to see that I mean like
we were expecting to sell at least a
hundred thousand units at its batch or
to have you know forty percent bodies
that they were able to use to in the
Crowder's word but it was just not
possible in the C work we're working
with Jonathan Kaplan yeah what was the
atmosphere like for for flip within that
Cisco a culture so the attraction
people's apart even I wasn't a cool
office in San Francisco far away from
San Jose at headquarter but every time
they do had to get out of the
opportunity San Francisco and have any
sort of interaction see bigger city
organization you were just reminded that
you have all these like boundaries and
all these wall and on yourself and
everything but there's like really
beautiful so you take me you know thirty
minutes to approve some thing with my
boss Jonathan and then two weeks to get
they've all you're strong so even though
our focus is on branding you saw that I
put culture runs parallel with branding
and what you just described was that
there was a tremendous culture clash
right that the cultures didn't mix so
even internally there was a big problem
with the culture so this the culture of
what flip was and and I know Jonathan
and I was at flip at the beginning and I
used to come over to the office San
Francisco because again if it's around
you know rich media social I'm there
right I'll sniff you out real quick
so the culture in San Francisco for flip
was outstanding
you know you come up there first of all
you guys are right there but what's a
little street and alley
overlooking the ballpark in the marina
well that's great for creativity that's
has a great starting place and so I used
to go over there but culture around
branding is so important that this is
what I was going to actually say about
Google so if Google is shifting into
music anybody ever been over to the
Google campus isn't that like the
greatest playground Circus what did you
have up with five different restaurants
in the lunchroom seven chefs now that is
a great environment very akin to music
right open colors all of that so if I'm
Google and my actual culture is if you
ever come to visit us we got the
greatest creative lively volleyball the
founders riding around on futuristic
scooters it really you know this is all
happening in real life so music
obviously is a natural part of what
Google is right I mean that's
entertainment that's creativity so I
would start to market the culture of who
I really am I'm not just a search I'm
not just you know your mail I'm actually
the most creative place arguably you
know in the valley and the arguably
would be Facebook right there Facebook
would say hammer stop right there hold
the held in your tracks so and I'm a big
fan of Facebook as well but I'm saying
if I'm Google and I'm getting ready to
shift into music I'll start my marathon
branding now my new introduction is meet
what we really look like the people who
work here the atmosphere the wash you
can wash your clothes at Google if you
work there did you know that yeah it's
all you had work you don't know you
don't have to just going you
between atmosphere because it's always
been this metrologist kind of like a
engineering friendly thing and a lot of
engineers are not exactly it seems like
the hip-hop for so forth quite a lot of
the big industry so what is it exactly
about the Google look at the field of
place that is very okay well because
music creation creating of content um it
comes from the same side of the brain
that's why you know so many artists love
devices it's a natural extension of
their personality the creativity it goes
beyond it doesn't matter genre of music
you'll find that musicians love
smartphones love laptops love checking
in on Foursquare love it's from the same
side of the brain it's the same
characteristic that's that's what the
connection is and what I was saying was
that when you have a brand and a culture
like Google you actually already have
built in what you need to shift when you
begin to introduce new features or new
products into the family and that was
the point I was making so that
environment is one of the best
environments I used to go over there
every week about five or six years ago
and sit down with Jennifer feikin who
was one of the creators of founders of
Google video and orchid who is an actual
person and I sit down with orchid and
talk about things but I would look and
see this great campus in this beautiful
environment and so I'm only saying that
as a part of marathon branding and the
culture of who you are if you utilize
that it makes it a lot easier to
introduce new characteristics to
transition if your brand it's been
around for a while all those things all
of those things are easier and so social
media has created transparency this
transparency has created an opportunity
for you to extend the life of your brand
and the wholeness of who you are
previously the only way to get this
information
out was a short story here in a magazine
if a writer does a story here and maybe
if you get lucky something happens so
you know out of the norm you end up on
the news good or bad infamous or famous
but with social media on these platforms
office all these platforms in real time
were able to tell the story and get it
out so if you're going to create new
behaviors introduce new products do
these things marathon branding arm it's
great to use these the social media
tools mention that first of all as you
mentioned the increased transparency
that you have and the wholeness of
yourself that you put out there what do
you do about the cases where that whole
person transparently exposed is not
exactly what you might want for Grammys
I mean you mentioned Lady Gaga and the
target thing but you can think of other
examples where celebrities you know done
something they shouldn't have and thanks
to social media everyone finds out right
away and when you or a person or concept
are brand
how do you mitigate those arrests well
arm so we can go a few ways with that
right because one of the problems that
has previously been created by both the
the celeb brand and the controller's of
the messaging of the brand right is that
there is this spotless flawless
individual whether he's a musician or an
athlete or whoever he is and it's not
realistic one of the things I love about
Nike is when you again talking about
marathon branding Nike allows for its
athletes celebs that it's connected with
to have flaws to be real to have
challenges and they don't just bail out
like a lot of brands do they don't they
don't just bail out so now you know if
you see the Nike product affiliated or
associated with an athlete or
entertainer that has had any type of
challenge it's not big new
to you it's not abrasive to how you
perceive the product because again I
call them a marathon Brander they made a
decision in-house that they would stick
with a a Michael Vick in some aspect
they stick with a tiger woods' that they
stick with and so the consumer initially
there may be some feedback blowback but
what happens is as they see that listen
we've always been human and that's what
I mean by the whole so in some aspects
Charlie Sheen he told you I'm winning
man it doesn't matter that from your
perspective I'm no longer at my current
job or partying a little too much from
your perspective or whatever it is that
you think Here I am transparent here's
my message I'm winning and at least
allowed him to balance the field right
immediately he balanced the field for
his brand so so so my take is is that if
you utilize these tools and even though
as you just pointed out there may come a
time where you know there's the parting
of interest right it goes back to you
know what you just saw politically
happening between President Obama and
who just like yesterday no no no that's
yeah but that too yes Netanyahu just
recently right so you would have to two
things happening and you have your
interests and then you have your moral
position and that's what they're
debating the interests and moral
positions that's the big debate no
matter what side of the fence no matter
how deep you dig moral interest that's
being played out right before us and
sometimes you just have to let these
things play out be debated and then you
you try to take best practices and work
them out so that's the same thing with
being hold and being open and being
transparent you've got to take the good
with the bad
very kind of strategy to make it on as
much funding right right
the challenge with Daddy is that most of
the companies that are small they don't
they don't stay small long anymore
right there's it happens to us you you
have to turn away capital these days
right currently in this environment but
but to your point if I were to just you
know think of some you know some small
companies that are doing things there's
a ton of them because I like to startup
culture so there's a lot of startups
right now that are doing a lot of great
things look at the App Store like look
at your favorite apps on the iPad a lot
of those apps are already so much a part
of my day-to-day life but you know I
couldn't do without them I wouldn't want
to do without them and then on the other
side I have to say that companies like
you know flip not Flipboard Flipboard I
really love you know their product and
I'm you know a big fan of it the way you
know consuming you know social media in
a digital magazine way that it's done is
outstanding so that's a company that
that I thought that I liked a lot that's
smaller right now but won't be small
long it's a little bit of a transparency
of actually designers and I think I work
with a lot of athletes I think the
difference in when you position yourself
from an Indian standpoint is that the
company like like we have people that
are regarded as aspirations because they
do superhuman things how do you as a
company like Google reposition yourself
to say our employees are aspirational
they live
they represent so Avengers when it's so
very different than a kid who's grown up
trying to get their voice in the world
through our creativity they see someone
with a PhD after who how do you make
that connection so that that person
would come to aspirational for this
person because musicians artists
generally they try to find a way with
their voice right no voices the medium
will choice whether it's music our dance
and poetry getting in trouble in some
cases but they necessarily don't see
themselves as being an employee of
Google someday for being a person who
cares about which the first step at a
brand saying we're going to change our
position we'll do the marathon branding
because people can see themselves as a
person who the brand cares about how
does Google which is a faceless formless
entity become humanistic so that a
person can say I see myself as being
part of who I see myself as someone who
cares about I see you know it's alright
right so they should start actually
doing that so a presence in the
community right so if they create a
presence in the community outside of
their core competency right so in other
words um a lot of us do charity work
together here in the valley all the time
all kind of causes now why not take
those tools all the tools right and let
some of the kids in the community tell
their stories and those stories are
brought to you by Google so if you're
going into my old neighborhood you know
in East Oakland and you empower and give
the tools and say listen what is your
story
what do you hope to be wait let's make a
short film on that we want to make a 10
minute film that willing to provide you
the tools Google has just partnered with
in my case Brookdale Recreation Center
they want to put the tools there you can
come there now when you create your
story you know that Google cared enough
to come to your community and not and
believe me this is all you know
hypothetical because they do a ton of
charity work as well but it was Google
who supplied the necessary means for me
to tell my story I think it's a good
starting point to do things like that in
the communities um that you're targeting
and the demos that you're targeting show
them that you can
by being there I think it'd be a good
start because it becomes organic and
authentic can you talk a little bit
about first program like how you went
through like how you started shifting
preferences through momentum marketing
how you got your music into clubs how
you started handling harnessing social
media to handle negative feedback about
you or how to create that dialogue sure
so just initially you know social media
or any of these platforms starting
before we call them social media so if
you go back to the YouTube initial error
utilizing YouTube to just get the
archives out there was a big important
part of my own personal brand by saying
that you may know me for one song here's
another song another song here's another
album
here's another short film you may have
missed about the life of hammer all
these things when YouTube first started
before I did you know become the
behemoth that it is today but in its
infancy I had a lot of presence with a
lot of my historical you know my
historical music work there and it
helped introduce it or reintroduce it to
to different audiences and so they were
able to to get a bigger snapshot of of
Who I am again as a whole brand secondly
um before it was considered real time
and transparency any negative you know
feedback
I was always quick to make remove the
velvet rope and communicate back with
the crowd not to the extent that I was
trying to necessarily create a new fan
but to just create the human aspect that
we just spoke about so once I was able
to humanize Who I am I'm not a
fictitious character from another planet
but I'm actually a a person beyond the
music beyond the song beyond the dance
and that connection utilizing those
tools early
on also helped to to deal with any you
know purported negative feedback because
all III know my brand better than
anybody
so I also knew it at the same time that
if I'm a brand and I'm the leader in his
face and let's say I sell you know ten
billion pairs of sneakers there might be
a you know another brand out there who
is envious of my brand but at the end of
the day they're still only selling ten
pair of sneakers so I'm not going to put
too much emphasis on my competitors and
I always knew that as well as a brand I
know my brand so when there is negative
feedback I also consider the source of
my of the feedback and are they truly a
fan of the product or competition and if
it's a competition then I address it in
one aspect and hopefully give them
enough information to give them a new
perspective
but if it's a fan I try to give them
enough information to alleviate any
fears so that they can continue to to to
engage for the whole ride the whole
story so that's how utilize social media
I'm there for again whether it's good
bad or otherwise but I do i but I am
wise enough to pick and choose on why
engage with so if I choose to engage you
that means that I see a tremendous
upside in answering your challenge and
in answering arm the competitiveness
because I believe that my brand overall
and in the marathon of it all in the
long term that I'll come out
you know shining on the other side so
that's kind of my approach that any
build on the point you mentioned earlier
about Lady Gaga defy that sheeting to
stages or first designer cropped a
message then the first or just embrace a
message and they were the ambassador of
that brand how do you craft studies
message to make sure you're going to be
embraced how do you design it how do you
work around making sure that love you
what trying but number I mean see so how
do you do it well the reason why I put
the word marathon out in front of
branding is that you have to be
committed right because the initial
feedback when you start to define the
brand initially may not be what you
thought you may not get to the desired
results initially on people may not know
who you are another good example if we
just you know using musicians in this
case is Nicki Minaj right so who she is
today is not who she was when she first
started right but at some point if you
you know google her and look at her
history you'll see that she started to
introduce more characteristics of who
she is
as she went along and I remember in our
house
early on I told my my two of my
daughters that I like Nicki Minaj and it
went for them they was like dad what
what you know dad I said I said you know
initially um I see a whole lot of talent
there is what I told my daughter's I
said I'm not listening to every word
she's wrapping right now that's that you
listen to every word daddy's not
listening every word I'm looking at
talent right here and I felt as though
um you know because because in my
household as a father right I'm put my
other hat on in my I'm raising five kids
and two nephews right so I'm not the
biggest fan of a tremendous amount of
profanity being thrown around my house
just that's dead right so when they
heard me say I like Nicki Minaj early
right
but you know her early music they were
like that but you don't always you know
subscribe to baba said well that's not
what I'm telling you what I'm telling
you is I'm seeing other people attack
who she is is what I said at that time
and I said but I see a greater brand as
you know down the road and you know I'm
certainly not the architect of it but I
watched her evolve into what I thought
she could become and the qoodles really
is to her because I see that she's very
independent
and she asserts herself and so what I'm
really saying is that initially the
feedback that you're looking for it
might not be the feedback that you get
but you have to be willing to run the
marathon now in music that's tough
because they're under a tremendous
amount of pressure to make quarterly
numbers which is what helped run the
music business because we went from I'm
going to make a great album and I put 14
songs on and song number one and some
some number fourteen actually connect
there's a story here but when they
introduced first week numbers they
changed the entire music business they
change into a game of a sport of who
hits you know the most homeruns in the
first week not even in the season you
may hit 10 home runs the first week and
that's it at the end of the year how
many did you hit 10 but they wanted to
make quarterly numbers they needed to
and so they put the emphasis on the
first week the first quarter is what
they were trying to do and so now you
have to pay for point of purchase
so stores like and it wasn't you know
obviously just Best Buy at the time
because I'm going all the way back but
Best Buy has to charge you for point of
purchase so if you want that new album
out front for the first week you want
counterspace it was fifty cents for this
counter space now it's $2 because you
wanted for this week so that changed the
dynamics so now the record companies
could no longer stick with an artists
for the marathon for their brand because
they had to make first quarter numbers
so you wouldn't have had you know the
opportunity which again is kudos to you
know cash money and and and their
company and Birdman because who Nicky
Nicky is they allowed her and stuck with
it and watch the brand grow so the the
parallel for you is that I'm making the
analogy that I'm making is that even if
you don't get the feedback initially if
you determine from the beginning that
you're going to be in it for this brand
for the marathon then it allows you to
get the feedback being being beta change
some of the characteristics are based
upon the feedback from the community
in the crowd not from competitors this
is you know most important for the music
business most of the fans and followers
on certain sites are all want to be
musicians so you're never going to get
nobody's getting 5 stars
because most of the fans around those
tights want to be the artist but if you
can carve out who actually likes the
artist you can look at the analytics and
tell who like it really is
Ginuwine and their affection for that
artist then you can begin to shape the
brand a little better so I hope that
answered some of some of what you were
asking this is how I'm including crazy
character and character so how do you
decide at what point do you pull that
selection out of it there's someone
who's treating the cartoon first real
person well today arm again we have to
be sensitive because we streaming right
so even when I just named off some of
the names you know I was being sensitive
to you know fans and business people
feeling associated watching and maybe
not understanding we're doing strictly
business arm so but right now in that
space of in the space of entertainment
character characters probably are
working better right again if you look
at the top 10 artists and you point out
the characteristics of the top five
those are not people normal people
walking around that are going to walk in
and sit next to you in the wave they
either address or their positioning so
right now the to cut through you might
want to get a purple hat and a pink
shirt and some green shoes just to walk
in and catch everybody's attention and
then once you get there their attention
because again we're talking about
marathon and the whole person you start
to introduce the other characteristics
again if you go back Lady Gaga day one
to Lady Gaga today with an agenda a
political position a social position
mobilize crowdsource audience monsters
little monsters this is who I am all of
that now from here right so characters
can be very powerful long as you don't
you don't
to overdo it for the long haul so that's
kind of the answer don't overdo it for
the long haul it's and they do it on
their own I'm watching I'm watching from
an artistic standpoint the artists will
take that character to a certain point
don't worry I got a guy I got a bunch of
kids so I understand the characters
they'll take it to a certain point then
they pull back on their own now like and
not to overemphasize it but Lady Gaga I
said this is who I am this is who I am
wait a minute I don't like you you're
talking negative against a certain group
of individuals and I want my voice heard
so characters step aside and now the
woman would like to say something to you
I don't agree with your message and
here's my message I'm going to defend
this particular cause or group so I
watch artists today they'll create a
character but then they'll also step
outside of the character and deal with
issues unlike previously we've had in
the last 10 years certain athletes who
never addressed one issue who had all of
the voice could have addressed issues
could have been very helpful in a lot of
ways but if you look at their history
they never addressed one issue they just
they were happy to be that athlete there
were names you're smiling
was a couple of them though but they
remain nameless and that's okay because
again
it can't be forced upon you you can't be
you can't like join the activism class
hit again and say I'm an activist and
you walk around Stanford all day to
saying you're activist and somebody said
well what's your issue
I'm activists it's not going to work too
long you have to really have an idea and
the issue and it has to be organic for
you know to be engaging
you want to be open and honest and
transparent but at the same time someone
who look back and let's say for you to
see what you're doing 20 years ago and
compare that to who you are today for us
you know that'll be true in 20 years and
please go but lay meaning for us like
tweets that I send out today you know
which which are funny to me and maybe a
little on PC are still going to be
around right 15 20 years how do you
manage image changes what's appropriate
well for me personally I really view the
world as real real-time actual real-time
right and again I'm also keenly and
acutely aware that the National Archives
brought to Twitter holes you do know
that right so every tweet is being held
forever in posterity all of your tweets
not some of them every one of them
wanting to the national historic
archives to be recalled 500 years from
now and I'm aware of that so so for me
um if I tweet it I can stand by it if I
tweet it even as a joke I can live with
it because one of the things that I'm
emphasizing as a personal brand and
marathon branding is I refuse to be one
thing because I don't know anybody who
is just one thing even if you look at
all of your hits your heroes
historically we know that they all had
flaws so I don't want to be the flawless
hero or mr. perfect none of those guys
or brands will survive in today's real
time world the new heroes will be the
heroes that have flaws that's the new
heroes why because they're really like
you they're closer to you so the old
positioning of you know creating this
character spotless sinless ba ba ba
it won't work and if you take that
position
you don't have to overanalyze every
tweet you don't have to worry about
everybody do they agree with it by the
way since you guys are going to run
enterprise you're going to run the new
businesses you also won't judge your
your your employees the way they're
saying you're going to be judged in
other words what are they telling you
that you better be careful of everything
you say on Facebook and on Twitter and
all that because when you go in you put
your resume and they're going to review
it they're going to see that you and
you're not going to get a job well it
depends always doing the reviewing if
that person also tweets and on Facebook
they have said something they're gonna
go hey you know I've said 20 things I
wish I could take back so in the future
it won't be as sensitive and issue but
yeah an answer you know your question
James that my thing is to be whole and
to be full of possible you know flaws
that's that's the journey you know
that's the journey there in this room if
you haven't made any mistakes you
wouldn't be here right now the fact that
you are here surprised it's the product
of some mistakes that you have made and
yet you ended up here each and every one
of you guys so you know branding really
is marathon branding is about
understanding that from the beginning
build that into who you are
build that into your brand at a listen
I'm I'm not flawless but I can tell you
that if we were to argue you know
Republican and Democrats you know I said
before the election I said wow the
Republicans won't get this back for 16
years
samer what are you talking about they
haven't even lost the first one for four
years I said no they won't get it back
why because they're pointing out every
flaw of everybody that they can and then
what that does is set you up because now
they turn the camera back and say oh you
did this and you're saying that his
platform is not the one I should vote
for because he's not flawless well you
see what happened with that was even two
years in I want to see your birth
certificate it's the way it's the way it
works once you start focusing on that my
noon I'm going to fall to find a flaw
you know even recently
you mentioned it earlier adjacent and
you do a name out and I won't throw that
name back out but that name started
saying again I'm going to go to this
issue that is you got handled and what's
the next issue let me see your academic
record it's nonsense
this is not what we're about in this
generation we want substance we're
living in real time we want to know how
we're going to fix and solve problems
and issues and no one person or one man
has to but the community can solve it
because the other side of social media
and I'm setting aside branding right now
and just talk specifically social media
is that now we can crowd source
information from the world so all of
this distant learning all of these
brains are all now connected so when we
say solve it is not just solve it me
it's not just solve it Stanford it's
it's all of us solve it and we're all
connected and we can all give an input
it's a whole new world it's a whole new
place a whole new paradigm shift all
right one more question
great I'll pose it so for a Cuba what
would you hope for her personal brand ah
so for my daughter kiba's personal brand
so she is a hook um horn she graduated
from the University of Texas last year
last year Oh another one all right and
there was one more in here on the
commercial oh yeah and I want to I'm
going to retweet that commercial
that's what I wanted to do we talked
about Nike earlier so I want to retweet
that commercial um but what I hope for
for KI but while I'm doing that is that
that Akiba is comfortable enough that
she's you know taking my advice to feel
like she's not under any pressure to be
anything other than whatever she wants
to be whatever she want to do but
utilize these tools I mean she'll hold
you 22 now keep at 23 say daddy action
23 sigh really goes she's 23 now you
sang in the Opera at 18 so I know you
can sing you made
you've got two degrees in four years so
I know you can think see so she is
academic and you always have been very
independent
you left graduated went to Spain for six
months I had a concert in Belgium and
you showed up you navigated through
Europe by yourself so um I had no idea
so I know you know how to navigate the
world I know you have talents and gifts
and everything so my dream for you is
whatever makes you happy but but but do
it just do it do it comfortably that's
what I hope for her brand I hope that
your brand ultimately really means to
somebody that you're a difference maker
that you will impact the world from a
humanity standpoint no matter what the
gifts you use at the end of it they'll
also say Ellen she's a good you know
person she helped them do this or help
with that sighs Wow sorry so what what
is his name I promised I would our
Kaelyn California no no no Kaelyn wasn't
between the video though yeah max max
was - exactly
see now you know half your intelligence
is recall you know I always tell people
that it's like short-term recalled is
like really like the best right so you
don't have to be smart then you just
have to like have great memory so wall
hammers ah yeah they are there you are
all right oh so you were listening to
the stream uh-huh yeah all right all
right all right
see that I like that so for those of you
guys want to know more about sort of
social technology not from a personal
brand perspective go online and just
google hammer at Stanford he has a
couple of videos last year he did one
for post power social technology with
Robert Scoble Louisa moon and also garth
saloner
so that's on on on video so I would
encourage you to check that out because
the chapters that go by with hammer at
Stanford are quite remarkable and
someday is going to let out that person
Brown case gorgeous piece of work on
personal brand
thanks so much hammer all right thank
you